the good news they're not telling you
that's the focus of tonight's angle if
you just landed here from another planet
you would think that the only news
stories that matter are the alleged
Trump Russia collusion Robert mother's
flying subpoenas and the growing gaggle
of a list gropers but what you wouldn't
hear much about is what is perhaps the
most important story of the year America
is back yea though the media has been
loathe to report this fact 2017 has been
a banner year for the US economy an
incredible comeback from President
Obama's anemic non recovery recovery The
Economist this week notes that
blue-collar wages are rising as
unemployment tumbles wage growth among
factory workers drivers and builders now
exceeds 4%
theirs is growing faster than the wages
of professionals and managers and when
you dig deeper there's even better news
the trades are thriving some building
contractors are seeing their wages grow
by double digits year-over-year that is
great news so why are things working so
well well first of all he has a great
team in place President Trump
guys like Wilbur Ross at Commerce Steve
mentioned at Treasury and what Axios is
calling a rising star in the
administration in Bob light hyzer the
president's US Trade Representative what
he does and does it really well is he
advances president Trump's america-first
vision in global trade dealing so you
know what I say with light hyzer in
charge
look out Beijing look out South Korea
watch it Mexico and any other country
that is gaming the deals that we
negotiated in good faith light hyzer
remember this exclusive interview he
gave us said this about finally
establishing an equal playing field we
should be in a position to defend
ourselves for the same amount of vigor
I think that this president will do that
but that is a genuine threat it's a
combination of massive subsidies of
closed markets now his policies in this
pro-american posture is already
benefitting American manufacturing and
the American worker you already know
that the stock market is experiencing
record growth but did you know that US
housing and industrial production are
also up things are rebounding so
robustly that the Federal Reserve Bank
in New York is projecting a 3.8 percent
rise in the gross domestic product
that's up a week ago just from a week
ago
and if that projection holds this will
be the best quarter for the US economy
in three years now do you remember when
people were laughing when Trump said
this we're gonna win with every single
facet we're gonna win so much you may
even get tired of winning now who's
laughing at him now I don't get tired of
winning by the way wedding is fun and
just to show that this is a president
who knows how to keep his own house in
order
on Friday the Trump administration
released their annual report on White
House personnel there are 110 fewer
employees working for President Trump
than work for Obama
you know what that saves taxpayers it
might be a drop in the bucket the
overall budget but it saves taxpayers
5.1 million dollars annually I'll take
that savings and an Ingram angle fun
fact Melania Trump has four staffers
compared to Michelle Obama's meager
twenty four and did you know that the
president has donated his entire
$400,000 salary to the Department of the
Interior and that money is going to be
used to pay for construction and repairs
to our military cemeteries I love that
so while others continue to parrot these
conspiracy theories and cover issues
that mean not that much to the daily
lives of most Americans you should
know that things are getting
demonstratively better in big ways and
it's small and it is shameful and it is
biased that these presidential
accomplishments get so little coverage
but I'll tell you something here in the
Ingraham angle we're gonna fix that we
all have a little more to be thankful
for this year which should be reported
honestly and celebrated and that's the
angle